this video was brought to you by
skillshare
hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
a lot of you that are fans of all things
space related or even just following the
journey of spacex
would have at least heard of starlink an
ambitious plan to revolutionize the way
we think about satellite internet
but today let's get into the details
what is styling
how do you go about building a global
broadband internet service in space
and what are the larger implications for
spacex as a company
let's take a look you are watching cold
fusion tv
[Music]
starlink is a network of orbital
satellites its aim is to enable almost
anyone
anywhere on the planet to have access to
a broadband internet connection
the development of starlink began in
2015 when elon musk stated that there
was an unmet demand for low-cost global
broadband capabilities
he thought that this demand was
significant enough to be very profitable
the first prototype satellites were
launched into orbit in 2018.
with the data spacex received they could
fine-tune the technology
by january of 2021 after about 20
launches spanning three years
starlink had over 1 000 satellites in
orbit and it now serves more than 10
000 customers who are in its beta
testing program
and by may of 2021 starlink had received
over 500
000 orders so it is clear that there is
indeed demand spacex can build 120
satellites per month
and wants to release 42 000 satellites
by 2027.
this is pretty crazy because only about
8 000 satellites have been sent into
orbit
since the soviet sputnik mission in
1957.
[Music]
spacex president gwynne shotwell states
that starlink
quote is best suited to rural and
semi-rural populations
in places where the internet is
unreliable or unavailable she went on to
state that starlink is not a replacement
for giant providers like at t
and comcast but rather very
complementary to the services that they
provide
interestingly the potential for styling
to be better than existing ground
internet
is possible and we will talk about this
later in the episode
speaking at a satellite conference in
april of 2021
shotwell stated that the company will be
quote able to serve
every rural household in the united
states or roughly 60 million people
starlink will um serve the hardest
to serve customers that uh
telcos otherwise have trouble doing with
with landlines or even with with
uh cell radio stations you know with
cell
cell towers 60 million people is a huge
market for just the united states
so there's a great deal of earning
potential here and if we consider
worldwide
the potential user base is massive these
internet beaming satellites get put into
space
by spacex's falcon 9 rocket which
usually releases
60 satellites per launch so the customer
setup is as follows
the styling hardware simply includes a
satellite dish and a router
which you'll set up at home to receive a
signal from space
so why do this all in short to make
money by solving a problem
back in 2018 elon musk stated that
starlink would help provide
spacex with the revenue needed to fund
the company's long-term ambition to
establish a base on mars
he estimates that it could generate
between 30 to 50 billion dollars in
annual revenue by 2025
when the service has over 40 million
subscribers admittedly that is a very
lofty claim
and we'll have to see how that pans out
as for the problem starlink is trying to
solve
laying fiber optic cables is expensive
and infrastructure can be just plain
impractical in some areas
for these scenarios satellite internet
makes more sense
if it can be done cheaply enough but
that's not to say that building
satellite internet is easy
it involves launching rockets into space
after all
but there's less competition in that
sector and spacex
is the best rocket company around
reliably delivering payloads into space
for many clients
at lower cost than anyone else with
reusable rockets
not only this but the company just took
their second crew to the international
space station
but with a reused capsule and a reused
booster
a historical first basically
spacex has made rocket launching become
routine
look no further than their rideshare
website where with the click of a button
you can select what payload you want to
send into space so say that i wanted to
send a subscriber to space
let's say they weigh about 90 kilograms
i'll just select that
and there we go so with this pedigree in
mind
spacex is the best company to launch
thousands of satellites in a
cost-effective manner
each satellite costs about three hundred
thousand dollars a lot cheaper than
other communication satellites
because spacex also builds their own
satellites
they've baked in some pretty cool
features for example
the krypton plasma thrusters are just
awesome according to a 2019 spacex press
release
the thrusters allow for the satellites
to autonomously avoid debris
automatically correct their trajectory
and when their time orbiting the earth
is up
they can safely maneuver themselves to
self-destruct by positioning themselves
to burn up in the earth's atmosphere
the release also stated quote
additionally
95 of all the components in the design
will quickly burn in the earth's
atmosphere
at the end of each satellite's life
cycle exceeding all current safety
standards
with future iterative designs moving to
complete disintegration
starlink currently has over 1 200
working satellites in orbit
and by 2025 no less than 11
943 of these satellites will circle the
earth and as mentioned
the final system will have 40 000 plus
satellites
and when this system is completed it
should look something like this
in this animation by mark handley you
can see that the satellites will blanket
the earth
the first 1500 satellites will operate
in orbits of 550 kilometers or 341 miles
above the earth
spread in 24 orbital planes inclined at
53 degrees to the equator
even right now if you head to the
satellite tracking website leo labs
you can see trains of styling satellites
traveling and criss-crossing patterns
it's pretty entertaining now here's
where it gets really interesting
starlink plans to use laser light to
enable the satellites to communicate
with each other
and when the lasers are used to connect
satellites to each other to create a
true network
styling has the potential to be faster
than ground internet connections
this is because light travels faster in
a vacuum than through
fiber optic cable a simulation by mark
hanley
calculates latency for starlink in a
connection from new york to london
a very important one for the global
financial system starlink latency is
under 50 milliseconds
while the current internet is around 70
milliseconds and the longer the physical
distance
the better it gets london to singapore
starlink 90 milliseconds current
internet 159 milliseconds
okay so far all of this sounds slightly
amusing
or even cool but you may be thinking
hey we've already had satellite internet
for a long time
so what's the big deal yes satellite
internet has been around since about
but starlink is doing it a bit
differently but to understand that
we first need to understand how
satellite internet came to be
the idea of satellite internet is almost
as old as the internet itself
it usually hinges on the idea of a
geosynchronous satellite
that is one that orbits the earth above
the equator and remains fixed following
the earth's rotation
interestingly this idea was popularized
by the science fiction author
arthur c clarke all the way back in 1945
this stationary satellite idea was first
done commercially in 1963
and then became adopted for use in
television military
and telecommunications applications from
the 1990s
when the internet gained popularity many
tried to take cyberspace up into
well space the most prominent effort
was the 9 billion failure of teledisc a
project partly funded by microsoft that
aim to have a constellation
of hundreds of low orbiting satellites
the project was eventually abandoned in
but in september of the same year the
first internet-ready satellite for
consumers was launched by utoolsat
satellite internet prior to starlink was
useful in both rural areas on the ground
and for airlines to allow internet while
flying but
it was slow many satellite internet
users would know
that the speeds aren't that great and
it's quite expensive for what you're
getting
and it takes a lot of time from the
signal to get to earth up to space
and back to earth again with average
latencies of about 600 milliseconds
and this is where space x comes in
to solve these problems spacex decided
to improve upon existing expectations of
satellite connections
by placing their satellites in a much
lower orbit than traditional methods
sometimes up to 60 times lower this low
orbit approach
means less distance for the starlink
signals to travel and thus
less latency latency plays a huge role
in time-sensitive internet applications
like delays and video conversation when
video calling or gaming
not only this but spacex decided not to
go for the geostationary approach
on the plus side this also reduces
latency but on the other hand
it makes tracking satellites much harder
because they're rapidly moving across
the sky
instead of hanging stationary overhead
so
here's a question how do the starlink
dishes on the ground
track and receive internet data from a
bunch of satellites
flying through the sky at a rate of
seven kilometers
per second well the way they do this
is also pretty amazing
[Music]
the starlink dish doesn't physically
move across the sky to track all the
satellites
because that would be ridiculous instead
there's actually
hundreds of tiny antennas creating a
phased array
these signals are processed by a large
integrated circuit
which adds them together intelligently
because the beam is moved digitally
rather than physically it can be scanned
so fast that it can accurately follow
any satellite moving across the sky
it can also be refocused near
instantaneously at another satellite if
the first satellite gets too close to
the horizon or is obstructed
technically you'd be able to use one of
these in the middle of the pacific ocean
and still be fine this setup is called a
phased array antenna
and it has its origins in military use
and is traditionally
very expensive so for spacex to bring
this technology down to the consumer
level
is pretty outstanding
[Music]
so the question must be asked yes so
starlink is doing all this fancy stuff
but how is it better than the state of
the art
we're targeting latency below 20
milliseconds
so somebody could could play a fast
response video game
uh at a competitive level like that's
the threshold for
uh the latency well according to ask
technica
the average satellite internet has
latency of 638 milliseconds
and according to cnet the average
download speeds range from 25 megabits
per second
to around 100 megabits per second
starlink in its early stages has the
following performance
according to beta testers between 50 and
175 megabits per second
with a latency of about 20 to 40
milliseconds
linus tech tips in his testing got about
138 megabits per second download
and 27 milliseconds latency according to
spacex
speeds should improve as more satellites
get launched and the network gets filled
out
the target speed will be 1 000 megabits
per second
or 1 gigabit per second for context in
perth australia
i get about 17 megabits per second and
50 milliseconds latency and i'm a three
minute drive away from the cbd
but i guess that's just australian
internet for you
but back to starlink they do state that
some interruptions in connectivity are
to be expected in these early stages
[Music]
so what about bad weather well that's
definitely one of the downsides of
satellite internet
as per starling's faq the satellite dish
is actually capable of melting snow that
gets on it
but it can't do anything about snow
buildup on either side or obstructions
that might block the satellite's line of
sight
it also reads quote heavy rain or wind
can also affect satellite internet
connection
potentially leading to slower speeds or
a rare outage
end quote
[Music]
so what about the cost well the styling
service isn't exactly cheap
on top of a 99 per month subscription
fee customers must also pay
499 for the satellite dish and the wi-fi
router
but after knowing about the technology
inside of the dish that kind of price is
expected
though spacex's president quinn shot
well
expects the upfront equipment cost to
come down to quote
the few hundred dollar range within the
next year or two
so we're almost at the end of the video
but before we end let's take a quick
look at the competition
so a company called oneweb which is
backed by airbus and richard branson
have launched a few satellites for their
global internet but filed for bankruptcy
in 2020
though they recently have secured 1.4
billion dollars in new
funding and then there's amazon's cooper
which is backed by the fortunes of
billionaire jeff bezos and they're
looking to join the race to provide
broadband services from satellite
constellations
but if you ask me i think spacex is
miles ahead here
though it has to be mentioned that there
are some negatives to this project
astronomers complain of light pollution
caused by styling satellites
painting the satellites black has been
proposed but some argue that this isn't
enough
the other main issue is if something
goes wrong in orbit say a tiny piece of
debris is coming for a styling satellite
and the satellite can't use its
thrusters to get out of the way in time
this would result in a cascading event
where collisions occur from too many
satellites in low orbit
though the probability of this happening
all depends on how good the autonomous
systems are on the styling satellites
if they are as good as claimed then this
shouldn't be an issue
so what about the implications for
spacex well for spacex
starlink is very interesting because
already the performance of the system
holds its own and is only set to get
much better over time
in other words much of the value of the
system is in the future
if the speed of the full satellite
system is anything like the simulation
that mark hanley calculates
having internet speeds better than
ground internet and being able to be
anywhere in the world
and receive a signal would really feel
like living in the future
the styling system is a huge feat but if
all works out well
and it turns out to be profitable it
could spell a bright future for spacex
although we should probably be skeptical
of that 50 billion
annual revenue by 2025 but even half of
that is a great achievement
and elon really does think that this is
going to be massively profitable
after all he has tweeted that starlink
might be its own spin-off ipo
so watch this space
if you want to discuss more about
starlink head over to the cold fusion
discord
there will be a new channel in there for
some discussion
before we finish off i just want to give
a shout out to skillshare for sponsoring
this video
skillshare is an online community for
learning anything from video editing
to productivity or graphic design i'm
sure a bunch of you know who marcus
brownlee is
he's one of the biggest tech youtubers
on the platform and he recently released
a course on skillshare
it goes through everything from
researching to writing scripts and
planning
for an actual video that he released on
youtube marcus did a great job here
and i thought the course was general
enough for anyone to pick up some
pointers
so if you're after some self-improvement
or just want to learn a new skill
skillshare has you covered the first
1000 people get a free trial
of skillshare premium membership and a
membership is only ten dollars a month
after that
click the link below to get started so
thanks for watching everyone
my name is dagogo and you've been
watching cold fusion and i'll see you
again soon
for the next episode cheers
[Music]